welcome back to the David Pakman show I
am Benjamin Dixon filling in for David
while he's away I'll be with you for the
rest of the week so I'm stuck in this
next story I feel a little a little bit
of ambivalence around because I don't
think it's worthwhile I personally don't
think it's worthwhile endeavor to engage
with Trump voters and people the Mogga
movement because they have demonstrated
to me and to most of the world that they
have zero intention of engaging
genuinely they have every intention of
being disingenuous in their engagement
but this story would seem to prove me
wrong at least in this case so here's
here's a little bit of anecdotal
evidence that maybe your time trying to
convince a Trump troll is worth your
while a former Trump troll gives a
passionate apology to former President
Barack Obama he did so in a series of
tweets on Twitter and I want to read
them to you now and then we'll let you
decide for yourself this is what he said
quote mr. Barack Obama I apologize for
all of the nasty things I've said to you
or about you thinking you were here to
divide and destroy America from the
inside I have learned so much in these
past several months my world has flipped
upside down I was a part of the group
who the next tweet says I was a part of
group that who thought you were a Muslim
who thought you were born in another
country I was ignorant to truly do
research I was ignorant to truly do
research about you that I did not make a
proper informed decision I trusted
propaganda and thought you were the
enemy of America
I thought you Barack Obama wanted to
make take all guns
I allowed anger and hatred towards you
sir to cloud my judgment from reality
and was noted in my columns that I have
written in the past I ignored your
accomplishments your love for soldiers
and said mean things I know you were not
perfect Barack Obama every every
president has made their mistakes but at
Barack Obama you are not the person
conservative media says you were you
cared about all Americans and try to
unite us
you tried getting people to see
different points of view you cared about
safety and tried your best to fight gun
violence you did care for military and
veterans and our country which I have
later found out again I am truly sorry
for my hate towards you Barack Obama you
are a decent human being and a good
president yes so what do you think about
that do you think that's a genuine
apology or do you think it's an
attention grab a lot of people in the
replies to this tweet said the dude is
really just trying to promote his blog
and get media attention like he's
getting but is it a worthwhile endeavor
to try to invest time into people who
have made a made it clear in most cases
in the majority of cases they've made it
clear that they have no intention in
engaging in good faith that they're
simply there to undermine your trust in
your belief system and to to try to give
the appearance I mean trolls are
literally paid to give the appearance as
though there is a massive amount of
people who disagree with your viewpoint
and when your viewpoint is based on
science let's say like global warming
and climate change and you know when
you're you're you know you have people
who are paid money to sit in chat rooms
god I just I just aged myself nobody's
in chat rooms anymore to sit on social
media and to relentlessly over and over
and over again make sure that they can
cast doubt in your minds I mean this is
literally the SIOP style strategy of
trolls on the Internet right very few
times are you engaging with people who
have that level of intensity that
they're just going to fight it out to
the very end in a lot of cases you're
dealing with paid trolls or to people
who have intentionally decided whether
they're paid or not to activate to
operate in that capacity and so it's
hard to take this example and believe
that it's really even worthwhile
spending time investing trying to
convince these people when they have
demonstrated that they have every
tension of a new ignore reality
rewriting history and just essentially
trolling now I want to give a little bit
more context for this guy I don't even
know if I mentioned his name what's his
name David Wells Weissman he wrote an
article so we will plug the article
because I think it's important to share
how this transformation happened and
this is what he said in his article he
said quote then came the moment that
changed my life and politics and social
media I accused self Sarah Silverman the
actress and liberals as a whole since
conservative pundits and media do this
of caring more about illegals than
American veterans to my surprise Sarah
Silverman replied and the resulting
dialogue was respectful months went by
and we interacted more on Twitter on
issues like gun reform daca and abortion
not only did I learn from her but I
learned from her followers who showed me
why they fight for these fights I
discovered sources of joy with
journalistic integrity which debunked
the lies and generalizations that
conservative media often report I slowly
began reevaluating my principles pause
all of that sounds good Dave what's your
name David Weisman all of that sounds
good
but it took you getting a response from
a a Hollywood star which means you were
so shocked like oh my gosh they're a
Silverman is talking to me of course
you're gonna take him in and be like
well what does she has to say what does
she have to say so I mean are we saying
here that the because people have been
telling you this all along David that
your politics are wrong people have been
trying to show you sources of in
journalistic integrity for a while I
guarantee you this is not the first time
people have approached you and so are we
saying that the catalyst for change is
for someone to be able to interact with
a television star or whatever I don't
even know I can't remember exactly what
Sarah Silverman starred in but that's
besides the point is that the magic
sauce because if that's the case we
might as well forget it and just keep
pressing on the way we're pressing
because not everybody is going to take
the time to interact with someone who's
admittedly a troll but I digress let me
not give this guy such a hard time
this next paragraph from his article I
think is actually worthwhile this is
what he said during the process a few
high-profile Twitter Trump supporters
saw me communicating with as opposed to
bashing Silverman and other liberals
like Andy Lassner and Chelsea Clinton
Chelsea Clinton the Trump train mob
turned their vileness towards me just
for talking respectfully to those they
saw thought of as an enemy i US Army War
veteran of 13 years was being called a
traitor to the country I never realized
how hateful this group was until I
became the subject of their abuse which
doesn't make me feel very good
from then on my eyes were open to the
kind of person Trump was and a moral
bully I would say immoral I really was
looking for the word in world there but
an amoral bully like his base that
supported and elected him well if
nothing else that paragraph is worth it
all because that's going to be the
absolute case the moment you show any
independent thought from conservatism
the conservative mob will jump on you
like flies on you know what